Charles is with us in Los Angeles hey
Charles welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey what's up how can I help people can
get some advice I only have around 7,000
dollars saved up next time here a while
to save that up and I have a $9,000 car
Harley's and all the Wonder and what I
should do if I should pay that off with
what I have now assembled ahead $9,000
is the buyout on the lease and you get
the title to the car yeah okay so you're
almost done and it's at a 20 percent
interest rate okay
you're sure because that that sounds
like an awfully cheap deal to buy a car
out completely you hang on it for around
two two years I've paid on it already
what car what kind of car is this it's
2009 what the NW BMW okay and $9,000 you
brought them a check for $9 they give
you the title yeah and you and you have
$7,000 yeah okay
well what we teach folks to do is baby
step one you set aside $1,000 as your
beginner emergency fund which means now
you have $6,000 and then you take all
the rest of money and you throw it at
your debt until your debt free if this
is your only debt then you've got six to
apply to the nine how's your credit well
I think that's why I got high interest
rate on it when I first got it and I
think it's gotten better because I've
got a low credit card I don't really I
don't use credit cards good okay can you
go to your bank and borrow $3,000 I
could second I'm not sure if you did
what's your income it's around 28,000
yeah okay if you can borrow $3,000 and
put it with the six and pay the car off
I'd rather you have the three thousand
dollar loan at the bank than have the
car loan at 20 percent
okay that gets to get you down then you
turn around and start working on that
3000 dollar debt is your only debt and
get it paid off as quickly as you can
meantime you got a one thousand dollar
baby step one starter emergency fund